قبل لحظات فقط استمعنا الى اصوات عده
انفجارات على مقربه من المكان الذي نتواجد
فيه اي في محيط مجمع ناصر الطبي في قلب
مدينه خان يونس جنوبي قطاع غزه هذه
الانفجارات نجمت كما يبدو عن اطلاق
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه لعده صواريخ
على هدف في هذه المنطقه وبالتاكيد لا ندري
الهدف هو منزل ام اشياء اخرى لكن في
غالبيه الاحيان الاستهداف يتم لمنازل في
هذه المنطقه السؤال الان هل هو منزل ماهول
وبالتالي غاره داميه يدمر المنازل على
رؤوس الساكنين دون سابق انذار ودون
تحذيرات مسبقه ام ان الامر يتعلق بتدمير
احد المنازل الفلسطينيه غير الماهوله
باعتبار ان بعض المربعات السكنيه شرق
مدينه خانيونس اصبحت مخلاه نظرا لعمليه
النزوح القصري تحت هذه الغارات والضربات
التي خلفت شهداء كثر واعداد جرحى كثير
وطالب جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بعض
المربعات باخلاء باتجاه الجنوب وبالتحديد
في منطقه رفح هذا بالتاكيد سوف يتضح خلال
الدقائق القادمه ولكن على الاقل حتى الان
نحن استمعنا ونستمع الى اصوات بعض
الانفجارات ولكن بعيده نسبيا هذه المره
على ايه حال هناك اصوات لاشتباكات تطلق او
تندلع في اكثر من مكان في خانيونس نستطيع
سماع اصوات الرصاص من اكثر من محور في هذه
المدينه وهذا
يعكس الاشتباكات التي تدور بين عناصر
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الذي دفع بلواء سابع هذا اليوم
لينضم الى سته الويه تقاتل فعلا داخل
منطقه خان يونس لوحدها وهذا يعني ان نحو
30,000 من جندي اسرائيلي ايه اصبحوا الان
موجودون في داخل داخل منطقه خانيونس
محافظه خانيونس وهذا الامر بالتاكيد يشير
او ربما ياتي بالتزامن مع كل ما يجري
الحديث عنه من تطورات واتصالات امريكيه
واسرائيليه وايضا اتصالات مكوكيه وزيارات
ومباحثات حول موضوع امكانيه التوصل الى
تفاهمات حول وقف لاطلاق النار لكن كل ذلك
ربما يريد من خلاله جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تسريع وتيره تحقيق الاهداف من
وجهه نظره ولكن في المقابل هناك من يرى
بان هذه الاعداد الكبيره تشكل ربما فرصه
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه لزياده غلتها من
الكمائن واستهداف هذه الاليات واستهداف
الجنود الذين اصبحوا بكثره بعدها الدفع
باللواء السابع شكرا لك والى دحدوح مراسل
الجزيره من خان يونس